[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
parlay that Ryan's gonna mess up that's
that's
uh we remember we remember how last week
went right
inform everybody how last week went Ryan
I said and you know Liv was on the show
and I I messaged bowling on the side and
I said you know bowling you would have
listened to me so you know I know where
to put the blame I'm not gonna put it
all on Greg but Liv wanted to go from
eight plus Julius Randle rebounds to 10
and I said live
hold on a second here my nightmare is
that we end at nine PL at nine and what
happened we ended at nine
and it's sold now I will say that the
rest of the parlay did not hit but for
my agenda that does but but the reason
the parlay didn't hit was because of you
that's not true because your Vibes are
is what created
that I will also I will also say Greg
the other leg that didn't hit was the
live leg so again not to just trash live
moves to just stretch live moves but
Buzz somebody here gave us two losers
okay and it wasn't me
you're making fun of someone who can't
defend themselves that's not really cool
in my opinion that's wild especially
someone as good as live
I need to protect myself at all costs
hey welcome to the show everybody uh my
name is Greg Ivory next to me is the man
I like to call MB his name is Michael
Bolin he is the app the man of the app
if you guys got any questions about the
app if you guys uh you guys go look at
our Bleacher Report app you will see his
face and next to him is producer Ryan uh
last week Ryan and his all-knowing
betting instincts tried to warn us Ryan
you wrote this
right who wrote this
this is crazy
I didn't think you'd actually read it
I'm not I'm not reading that I'm not
reading that let's let's it's time to
cook up it's time to cook up another
parlay drop your Best Bets for tonight's
TNT games in the chat Grizzlies chat oh
man I'm all discombobulated Grizzlies
calves Clippers bucks that was super
funny Ryan that was some good stuff
I need to get you back uh Ryan what are
the people talking about
okay
wait wait wait the first comment I
looked at says I'm Greg burgundy
not all facts lamb that was a perfect
perfect comment I love that Vibe I'm
over here crying laughing that was funny
oh god oh that was good all right well
first of all
uh call us posito said Pacers money line
again TNT games the Indiana Pacers are
like the Sacramento Kings they will
never be on National prime time so throw
the Pacers stuff away it's never
happening uh the starch also said
lamello three plus threes I will also
say the Hornets in our lifetime will
never be on TNT so again Grizzlies Cavs
and box Clippers
uh oh here's one king Russ Garland eight
plus assists so Darius Garland 8 plus
assists uh if you guys see something
else I see Donovan Mitchell from
gsmith813 Mitchell two plus three two
plus threes yeah Julia I like Randall is
is not on
the Grizzlies the Cavs the Clippers or
the Bucks indeed I will Circle back to
the eight assists I have a my handy
dandy note sheet here and on it I see
that Darius Garland has gone over eight
and a half assists in seven of his last
ten games that's pretty good if we're
gonna find a starting leg
okay and his line is eight and a half
so I'm down I mean you know I'm always
down to buy it down uh so if we want to
go eight plus and then see where we land
a few minutes from now I'm down here
yeah I like it I like it
yeah 170 to start
honest
Grayson Allen two two plus threes he's
hitting eight of his last ten home games
I know we're jumping around but you know
pretty reliable play
let's do it
although I will just get my general
frustration out as uh lowly Chicago
Bulls fan we hate Grayson Allen here so
we're gonna put this in and it doesn't
hit we will be spamming you my guy so
just know
another minus 170. not bad
yes not bad
now I appreciate you because there was
at one point in time where I I wanted to
take a Kyrie under for my you know my
Personal Agenda
um and you didn't allow it but you
you're over here you don't like Grayson
Allen and you're taking it over I
appreciate you for that
it's about women I just want I just want
to win that's all yeah I've always said
and been steadfast if I see Grayson
Allen on the street I'm gonna have to
have a conversation internally on
whether I want to keep my job or sanity
but that doesn't have anything to do
with us winning tonight so I will let it
slide good point uh Greg you said you
didn't like it why the bad vibes yeah
I mean I'm not gonna it is what did we
get that from the chat yeah of course
the the parlay's always from the chat
Greg all right it's good no you you come
push your agenda sometimes so uh I see
Kauai over 27 and a half points the West
Side McFly you can talk about it
I think I think I'd be down to fade that
I don't know 27 and a half points is a
lot of points faded he's been bawling
low-key go ahead let's make it the right
leg
let's make it the Ryan leg go ahead fade
it
[Laughter]
I love it he had 33 points in his last
game out against the Bulls like I said
probably not saying much before that hit
32 against the Hawks he's playing more
minutes he seems like he's healthy
had 27 against the Spurs
it's just what you said right there
it seems like he's healthy so that's
always the thing with Hawaii
all right so in January he's averaged 35
minutes a game
um so he's playing all the minutes he
can get he hasn't been under 25
since Feb since January 13th so if I was
if I were to put the leg in I would
start at 25 points because it seems like
that's a lot pretty much for this last
for the last month
can Giannis might be guarding him
yes oh that's a good call
can I propose something and this is
going to be us playing verbal ping pong
here but can we go back to uh I also see
uh megalito drops Brooke Lopez over one
and a half threes he's a corner three
Merchant according to him he is
megalito 11. oh oh sorry Brooke Lopez I
don't know who
oh yeah
the thing about Brook Lopez that's
interesting he's been he's had a hell of
a year first of all I'll just say that
um
I feel like with the big guys that shoot
threes like if they don't hit the first
one you're just like not confident
what about you does anyone else one
probably I could go with if it's one
three I'm down because then you just
need to see one go through the hoop yeah
but if we're talking two
that gets a little dicey
e
three picks for one plus 193 Ryan
and we're gonna get there Greg we're
gonna get there I promise you
G Smith 813 dropped before Donovan
Mitchell two plus threes and then we
went away we went away to the other game
is this a it's it feels like a
three-pointer kind of night for us
oh
a lot of people might not like that but
personally I kind of like betting on
threes to be honest with the people hate
you can get you can get through a parlay
pretty quickly if you you're on the
right track obviously it's all luck
we're just like forecasting but I'm not
I'm not I'm not against the three-point
parlay why not don't don't undersell us
bowling it's not all luck we know we
know oh two plus threes okay okay two
plus threes is minus seven fifty though
so we're gonna need to
like this isn't nah that's not gonna do
it
that ain't gonna do it see
we're in a pickle
all right help us get out of this
picture so sg-12 six rebound
oh
who oh Evan Mobley
is given to us
given to us by King Russ
six rebounds his line is nine and a half
so that's kind of Lucky
we're eating some dry fruit today though
because this is no juice whatsoever
I mean we're still at Plus 232.
hey we're tracking we need we need one
we need one long shot
okay how are we tracking we're tracking
now but we weren't tracking what we
added Donovan Mitchell two plus threes
what's the difference I didn't say
anything about okay true okay so I had
that I had that SG 132 Donovan Mitchell
owes us 21 points Darian says Mitchell
has been garbage juice lately check his
stats yeah hey they said take Mobley uh
plus us eight plus at least
said that
okay
now that puts us in a good position
see we're tracking see we're tracking
see
all right Jared Allen 10 points shout
out shout out Bagel unlocks Donovan
Mitchell hasn't gone over 24 since
dropping 80 a couple weeks ago that 80
which was actually 71 came against my
lovely Chicago Bulls so we'll never
forget you know I can't you're not
counting the nine points in overtime is
that what I'm assuming here
no no I think he ended with 71.
[Laughter]
at this point you guys keep filling up
the chat with uh with some Lots we're
looking for locks from the Grizzlies
Cavs Clippers Bucks game
so let us know
we do Jared Allen
we're there I mean it brings us lots of
stuff yeah I mean
I like it
I we're gonna see one go through the
hoop
I mean all we need is
like it's actually kind of scary how
quickly we did this uh
genuinely makes me nervous is Darius
Garland eight plus assists I think
that's really it
all right let me go while you go I mean
I said I gave the stats seven out of his
last ten he's gone over eight and a half
so the numbers support of this being a
numbers numbers are there are you so you
guys this is a good question
Pat myself in the back for the question
in advance are you guys if you guys are
not fade the trend people you guys are
ride the trend
definitely ride the trend guy
okay I mean like okay so let me ask you
like this if we're sitting at a roulette
table or we're walking up to a roulette
table and you see four Reds in a row are
you gonna play red or would you play
Black
I I personally would play Red I just
have a friend who's like very
anti-uh ride to the trend like he would
he would if there was four red he would
go black and like I don't understand
that
I'm going black I'm going black oh you
would so you would you would Buck the
trend then
well in this case in in roulette's case
yes I'm going black in that case what's
the difference for you though
what do you mean the rules why in
roulette and not embed it
because that's like to me Ryan that's
two totally different things
roulette is roulette sports betting is
sports betting
so I think I I agree with Greg I think
it's easier to Buck the trash
because it's like more random but I feel
like if you're reading trends for
basketball like I would rather Bank on a
trend than like try and buck it and the
guy's consistent and then you lose
person
yeah
yeah that's fair
also we
I feel like there's a lot that we
haven't
never mind I I'm I'm not I'm now the
more that we that we linger here the
more I get nervous about Evan Mobley's
rebounds I won't lie
all right well let's take a look I will
go I will do my due diligence on Evan
Mobley because I had Evan Mobley smoke
me once this year and I don't know if it
was on points or rebounds but looks like
according to my calculations
he's gotten
at least eight in
it's kind of it's kind of spotty I'm not
gonna lie I'm not saying as much as I
would like to last game out seven nine
eleven ten seven nine seven it's a match
up it's the match up though they're
playing the news I think I think no
Steven Adams I know for a fact I don't
know if Jaren Jackson's playing somebody
in the comments said Jaren Jackson maybe
he wasn't playing but I cannot confirm
that but it's the match-up think matchup
that that would make sense to me
um the match-up dictates it the
Grizzlies played last night a pretty
close game all four quarters so could be
a chance that
I don't know I like it Greg I'm I'm good
to leave it in there this feels like I
like it
I like it too I I don't we shouldn't
overthink it
um
sometimes when it flows that's the best
and it went up
and it's plus 420 now can we lock it in
just for the number
yeah I I
don't know and though I I noticed in
every number that you said you didn't
say a number below six
I never below six
you're only doing this just in case so
you have something to come back to this
is what great that I'm now peeping it
Greg I peep so now we're we're on the
same page because he's just he's still
just trying to get his agenda through I
don't understand how it happens
I don't know what specifically we're
talking about here I I just want us to
win so if he is never in those numbers
that you that you said never one time
below six well then why don't we just
take him at six plus and then we can
find a better place
yeah what are we doing bro we're wasting
time at this point let's just lock it in
and move on the chat wants it the people
parlay
like why are we overthinking bro
sometimes thing has to just flow like
water and we got this parlay we cooked
it up in like 12 minutes it flowed like
water let's bro
what are we thinking about oh man let's
do it bro let's do it can we thought can
we thumbs up oh by the way King Russ
said that he would skip the next play on
roulette and then play red and continue
to ride the trend interesting uh
I don't know about that no not sure
that's a smart way to do it but that's I
don't know what that does for you yeah
nothing you just it's not an opportunity
because what if it's red on the play
that you skipped are you still playing
red exactly
uh regardless uh all right thumbs up or
thumbs down uh oh we're not doing no no
no no no right we're locking in the
parlay look at the look at the comments
this parlay is a lock like the peoples
have spoken on this bro we're locking it
in let's just lock it in
let's just lock it in because I know
what you're trying to do you're trying
to push your agenda you're trying to see
a couple thumbs downs and then you want
to go and change some stuff up no no no
let's just lock it
he says yes look at trigger away
yeah okay those are two those are two
users I I would like their thoughts if
somebody said like John Moran eight plus
assist instead of Darius Garland I'd
listen to them but I just want to hear
them out
you're trying to sign you're trying to
silence the majority
no I'm not I'm trying to silence you
[Laughter]
because you're trying to push your
agenda on the parlay
now every week you're trying to silence
me and then what happens and then then
you get the clip on social media of me
saying I told you so this is what
happens you say that regardless you say
you you say I told you you wake up and
say I told you show you brush your teeth
in the morning and saying I told you so
you you open your computer and literally
type out that might be your password to
your computer I told you so because
that's just what you do that's just what
I wake up that's what you do I wake up
every morning I look at myself in the
mirror and I say and you say I told you
so exactly but I have a clip every week
to go along with it Greg so it's not
like I'm just making it up out of thin
air you know like you photoshopped that
slack message that that you had
like you're fictionalizing things and
mine's real
oh man right you are something else
brother
bro let's lock in the parlay what are we
doing do people want it
says he doesn't like Grayson Allen
threes
I see two of them I see ts22 says I
don't like Alan threes and then I saw
sg-132 saying Allen 3's thumbs down
if we want to get Grayson Allen about
the paint I certainly am not going to
uh
you know bowling you brought up a good
point before uh the lights went on on
the show that the Bucks may be a little
a little groggy because this is a 10 p.m
game for them they're I I cannot believe
whatever I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go
off on a rant but it's a very late it's
a it's a late start from Milwaukee Bucks
yeah I mean thank you
I'm sorry guys I'm so sorry to interrupt
y'all conversation I'm trying to talk to
the people uh
you're suggesting us to take off Grayson
Allen come with another play just don't
don't like don't just tell us you don't
like something and not come up with the
like come with a suggestion so if you
dislike something come with a suggestion
on like what you think we should replace
it with and then we can decide if we
want to actually think about it or just
move on
so I see a play from King Russ kawhide
II plus threes is way better
we were we were kind of on his uh uh
potential for 25 points or 27 points so
let me get in the lab and see what I can
see on Kauai I don't remember him being
very much of a volume three point
shooter but I also know that he probably
is shoots a pretty good percentage
I don't know if this is gonna do it for
us
it's not
it's not oh yikes
yeah we would have to adjust something
else
all right you know what I'm with Greg I
don't want to go in circles I think we
had it we had a good vibe
let's just lock it let's just lock it
and so we're not racing doesn't hit the
two threes I will fall on the sword and
add it to my little notebook of reasons
why I want to punch him in the face okay
and if if Evan Mobley doesn't get a plus
rebounds
what are we saying
he's gonna get eight rebounds Ryan yeah
that's what I'm saying bro like where
why why
like why why did you say that you said
no you said last week no you said no why
last week and then what I and then like
you said the words out of your mouth
last week
I want to talk about why did you just
bring up him not getting eight rebounds
when it's on our parlay like what's
going through your head to like bring
those vibes to the chat to the show you
know you have bright lights in front of
you you have a computer screen that's
that's recording you or that's you know
look I don't even know what I'm trying
to say like I just want to know why why
why
because I said it before and I just want
to bring light to it again it also Clips
better this time around
you know
you guys were talking about where you
guys were almost cutting me off the last
time I brought it up so I'd much prefer
to just have have my own little audio
space right now lock lock in the parlay
it's time
thank you so
what are we doing
read the foreign
this is why you're not a man of the
people you don't know how to read you
don't know how to read it Ryan you don't
know how to read it we flowed like water
we found this parlay that we cooked up
in 12 minutes we flowed like water to
get here you got to read The Vibes bro
I read The Vibes last week and The Vibes
screwed me so you know last week is over
Ryan please stop I can't I I can't
forget about the past when the past
haunts me Greg says I wake up every
morning saying I Told You So I wake up
every morning saying I I yell Julius
randle's name for the past week I wake
up in a cold sweat thinking about Julius
Randle and the rebound they call the
team rebound
that was his rebound that was his
rebound
that was rough that was tough whatever
that was tough I'm not gonna lie that
was tough but we got screwed but but we
also lost another leg so you're putting
too much emphasis on that one leg I feel
like yeah you're right it was a lot like
that lip dropped I forgot
yeah I hope that we have
a thing that and posting it to social so
Liv knows
live right here they've had a good
a shop call and it came up I think a
half Point short We're Not Gonna We're
Not Gonna Dance
no it was it was absolutely sharp yeah
I'm not either Mikhail Bridges had two
points at halftime but it was definitely
sharp for sure yes
Ryan ring to Parlay let's lock it in
brother
it's Darius Garland eight plus assists
Grayson Allen over one and a half made
threes Brook Lopez
Brooke Lopez one plus three
Evan Mobley eight plus rebounds Jared
Allen 10 plus points the odds are just
the odds are going up as we speak
as we speak it's five legs Plus 431.
39 brother 439 let's go 439 I can't keep
up that's how guys we could possibly
tease it down if we wanted to at this
point
we're we're closing line value Rich
right now
oh man
[Music]
um
if you guys want to tell our five leg
parlay make sure you guys head on over
to FanDuel to opt into the TNT Thursdays
no sweat parlay for a free BET
if it loses but we're not we're not no
no gvo is not a good vibe
Greg what are you saying if we lose
that before you wrote that
I didn't touch you rope
I didn't touch anything he wrote that
you wrote that all right that's crazy if
we lose you mean when we win
a lot a lot of gvos only uh
so we grade some bets
yeah can I just gonna say can we can we
find a squad ride because I think we
need a squad ride for uh for the app
tonight so we can grade some bets and
pick one for a squad ride if you guys
are down
there it is Evan Mobley six plus
rebounds what do you guys think
that's easy
that's a lot I know I know it's a walk
we'd also like to get some value out of
it not bet a minus 600 single play so
damn
[Laughter]
all right so hop in the chat and let us
know your best bet single bet for
tonight because we need a squadron
sg132
is in the chat and we're not we're not
changing the parlay parley's locked in
what did you see in the chat corner
did you see football Corner Q Hall
corner said take Garland's assists off I
just wanted to say q-haul Corner because
they're not going to listen to you I
tried I tried they don't want it they
said I was bad vibes Greg tried to kick
me off the show in real time he didn't
have access to the tech so we can't we
can't do it I'm sorry
trigger away says Giannis over four and
a half assists tonight what do you guys
think about that
that's a good one I don't hate it
I don't hate it what are what are your
what does your metric say bowling
my metric says that he has he's he's got
this number pretty frequently uh he
averages five on the season if it's
minus 130 so that feels like a good play
from trigger away I would give that an a
for sure
he has four four assists in his last two
games it went four four six so
I don't know I don't know what the here
how healthy are the bugs these days is
is Middleton back I have I haven't
watched uh bucks but it seems like
they're rolling at the moment
yeah I mean you can't bet any Middleton
props on here but uh if you want to do
four plus assists and feel better about
well no you can't because Giannis is
minus 270 unless you like that kind of
juice if that's your kind of speed
that's your deal
you know uh we got A.D over points and
rebounds let me go find the number I saw
Darius Garland double double in there
that's kind of hot play from Ab steel I
see that
what is that Greg do we know the of
course they didn't drop the value they
didn't drop the odds but
I'll do the leg work that's an
interesting one I don't know if we've
done a double double bet as a squad ride
yet that's kind of lofty I don't hate it
I'm with it
yeah I think I think that hits
plus 185 almost two to one value
that's a good squad ride bro I'm not
gonna lie Logan if you're out there
listening I think we uh I think we might
have found it yeah that's a good squad
ride not gonna lie I like it and it also
fits our agenda of him getting a plus
assist or unless he does it with
rebounds and if he does it with rebounds
and he doesn't get the assists I might
cry
I'll just be real I'll cry Ryan
you wouldn't cry you wouldn't cry why
did you say that I'm just letting the
people know that I would get in my bag
of emotions that's just what it would be
if Darius Garland doesn't get a plus
assist the same way Evan Mobley doesn't
get eight plus rebounds stop I could
probably cry but yeah I'm not speaking
into existence I'm just letting you know
if it doesn't happen I'm gonna there's
gonna be problems Ryan if you say
something if you say something out loud
that's speaking it into existence
brother like what are you talking about
like why are you even saying that so
should I just come in here every week
and and just start spewing he's gonna
get this he's gonna get that and then
we'll just hit every play we've ever
said because I've spoken into an
existence
I mean the way you're doing it now we're
we're still not winning parlaysia
because we're losing them because of you
by you speaking into existence now or
right correct Greg every great team
every great team has a great locker room
we can't be walking around here pointing
fingers at everybody and blame it on
other teammates okay
all right
last week on live she got kicked off the
team she got kicked off the teams not
kicked off the team she's just not here
today she got demoted to the minor
leagues she's on her AAA team
[Laughter]
you're wow
all right that's funny though I'm not
gonna lie but you're a wild one brother
you're well with my man Ryan's wow uh
let's Grace some more bets man let's
Grace some more beds
uh Grayson Allen under three under three
and a half rebounds
yeah I can't imagine he's I can't
imagine he's like mixing it up in there
that's some big bigs in this game
obviously Brook Lopez Giannis zubach I
don't think he's gonna be mixing it up
in there so I don't hate that one either
and he doesn't hate it can I try can I
try and experiment with the chat real
quick I've been thinking about this for
a little while
all right so Chad
please just like humor me for a second
if you had to hit a bet one bet
it's like gun to your head you cannot
lose this bet
and you need either Greg to pick it or
Ryan to pick it who are you picking to
make that bet for you get in the chat
and say either Greg or Ryan because I
love the Greg Ryan rivalry and I think
we're pretty even when it comes to
torture bets wins losses whatever we're
not even what are you talking about Envy
um
up up
yeah you are I'm trying to be nice
so who would you write thank you for the
attention
Greg Orion I need to see you in the chat
don't put my name down please
everybody put rad emojis
are you at your in support of who would
you rather have who would you rather
make the bet you said me
everybody put red emojis
telling yourself short
okay facts
[Laughter]
Greg would you let Ryan handle parlay's
money
[Laughter]
my dogs yeah
no chance right you suck Greg Greg Greg
you saw you saw what I did with my money
this weekend let's not all right you
know what happened no yeah you did hit a
parlay good job you do you you hit that
part late night that was that was a nice
hit bro that was you came to Vegas and
did what you had to do and you left up
yeah so I'm I'm happy for you I'm happy
for you I shout out to Zibby 326 saying
Sam Richmond that's fine that's the
smartest way to handle this not for real
for real
for real for real
Sam the sharp will keep us all alive for
sure Sam the sharp blue hey why are we
not why are we not shining light on
darien85 who said Ryan hasn't let me
down he's clearly been tailing the best
bet
what's the record for the best bet
nowadays
Bryson said he's pulling the trigger
that's crazy
[Laughter]
Ryan
read the parlay you you stole from the
people one more time I don't know how we
get the I don't know how we get the
whole stolen thing you guys didn't let
me say a word today this is the first
time I'm talking on this show
oh
you've been trying you've been pushing
your agenda the whole day holy I
don't know about that I don't know about
that uh chats parlay
here we go not my part like chats parlay
the chats parlay the chats parlay Darian
Garland Darius Garland eight plus assist
and I'm already off to a hot start we
can't do it Greg look he can't do it he
said trans parlay four times and then
fumbled his words because he's trying to
get that agenda out yeah I know he's
trying to he's trying to get that agenda
he can't help it oh okay all right let's
try this one more time
the chats parlay Darius Garland eight
plus assist Grayson Allen over one and a
half threes made Brook Lopez Brooke
Lopez one plus three made stop it Evan
Mobley eight plus rebounds Jared Allen
ten plus points five legs Plus 430.
screenshot it hold on hold on
screenshot it
screenshot that thing uh
any closing remarks
I feel good about this one man we've
been four we've gotten four out of five
the last two weeks it feels like maybe
not last week something about live
something about Ryan Thorne live under
the bus but whatever I don't know
we're doing Positive Vibes only and this
is a lot of gbos
a lot of gbos Ryan anything any closing
remarks
uh I think we're probably gonna need to
have a team pow-wow soon just kind of
like up the chemistry you know really
just enhance our locker room culture uh
but but other than that no no no no not
for me we're gonna win this one
I'm surprised you said we're going to
win this one I thought you were going to
um you know
come with your usual bad vibes reg a
broken clock is right twice a day you
know what I mean
they say that in the comments to me like
all the time when I hit a bet yeah
that's what they said that's what the
haters want yeah yeah
Oh Let's Get on Up out of here man some
money to be made y'all see the parlay
make sure you
screenshot it
make sure you're screenshot it uh my
name's Greg man my name is Greg Ivy next
to me is the man I like to call MB you
might call him Michael Bolin he is the
man of the app I was about to say the
chat but he is the man of the app and
next to him is producer Ryan producer
Ryan the guys that uh messes up our
parlays from week to week and likes to
say I told you so
[Laughter]
SunRail it's unreal but there's a
problem when I do it to live right
you're holding me accountable I'm trying
to live account you're here you're here
you saw the pause that I I I paused
after I said that so because I gave you
a uh some time to rebuttal you know what
I'm saying live is not here she's not
here she knows what she knows where to
watch the show she could she could be in
the chat if she wants to
you don't mind this is funny
hey
we we about to go win some money y'all
[Music]
foreign